let's turn to a practical issue and that
is the process of recalling dreams by
now you should all agree that we all
dream every night some of you may find
that you can't recall your dreams or
have an idea about last night's dreams
when you wake up but it seems to slip
away from consciousness within a few
minutes of waking up so what can we do
to enable us to recall our dreams
the first idea I have about this is that
you should always keep a dream diary
next to your bed also make sure you have
a pen or a pencil to write with now use
the diary and the pen for nothing else
other than dream writing so don't use it
to make notes on a project or to write
up a grocery list see the diary and the
pen as being very unique they are there
only for dreams every time you look at
the pen and the diary you remind
yourself that they are there to record
your dreams the sight of these objects
acts as a prompt to you each night as
you go to sleep those of you who have a
partner in bed may realize that they
don't really enjoy you switching on the
bedside light at 2:00 a.m. in the
morning so buy yourself a small
flashlight or even better still a simple
headlamp
you should be able to buy a small
headlamp from an outdoor or camping
supply shop for about twenty dollars so
when you do wake up and want to record a
dream you flick on your headlamp and you
don't disturb your partner the next
thing to be aware of is that you need to
remind the ego that it is going to be
recalling a dream when you wake up and
that this recall is going to be just the
facts so before you shut your eyes in
bed tonight say to yourself I'm going to
dream tonight when I wake up from the
dream whether it be during the night or
in the morning
I will recall my dream and be able to
write it down it is almost as though you
have to give the ego a little reminder
that this is what is going to happen
from now on when you do awake from a
dream put on your headlamp and begin
writing just record the dream don't edit
it use whatever words you recall as
there is no need to tidy up your grammar
or your syntax I do this each and every
day and later on in the day I type up my
dreams on my laptop so I have a good
record of them very very important
though when you do write the dream up or
type it up don't edit anything if you
dream of some strange word write the
word down and don't use your spell
checker on your computer to correct the
spelling very often we have strange
words and dreams some being combinations
of words often that don't make sense to
us initially when you get round to
interpreting these words you'll see that
the psyche is creating new words with a
purpose also if there are any numbers in
the dream try to write these down
exactly as well so if you dream of
buying a glass of wine for thirty
dollars and forty-five cents right this
amount down as you will soon find that
the number is tied into something quite
specific some of my patients keep a tape
recorder next to their bed and simply
press record and speak out their dreams
they then transcribe these recordings
later on the next day I do have some
people who use their laptops to record
their dreams this takes a little more
skill and there is always the
possibility that something doesn't quite
work and trying to sort out a computer
or a computer program at 2:00 a.m. can
be quite frustrating when I was in
Zurich doing my analytical training I
used my laptop for a short while
including one night when I typed out a
very lengthy
very important dream and I found out the
next morning that the laptop wasn't even
switched on at the time I had used it so
I went back to my trusty dream diary and
special pen another very important issue
is that you must provide the context or
the conscious attitude that the dream is
responding to remember how the
unconscious is giving a commentary in
the form of a dream to respond to a
conscious attitude well what exactly is
a conscious attitude the simplest way to
write this is to report what was going
on for you for the past two days prior
to the dream what were you worried about
what decision did you have to make who
are you thinking of or who did you have
dinner with or a phone call or a chat
session with finally always write the
date of the dream I write the date of
the night that I went to sleep so if
today is the 15th of March and tonight I
have a dream even if it appeared in the
early hours of tomorrow morning I write
down the date I went to sleep in
something else to pay attention to is
that sleep is easily disrupted so there
are a number of important behaviors you
need to manage before you go to sleep we
can refer to these as sleep hygiene
practices the first is that you should
really try to avoid any stimulants
during the afternoon I feel that if you
have any caffeinated drinks after 2:00
in the afternoon you often will have
disturbed sleep the second thing is to
avoid strenuous exercise for at least
two hours before you go to sleep and in
the same vein try not to have a heavy
meal just before you go to sleep either
the third thing is to be very careful
about what you watch on TV or read just
before you go to sleep reading a horror
story or watching CSI in Miami just
before you go to sleep may affect your
ability to get
to sleep and to stay asleep throughout
the night so there are some practical
ideas about how to recall your dreams
let's turn now to the types of dreams we
can have not all dreams are equal
most of our dreams are compensatory
dreams meaning the unconscious
compensates for the conscious attitude
with a dream some of these dreams may be
complimentary this means that the dream
complements the conscious attitude other
types of dreams are traumatic childhood
recurrent and prospective a traumatic
dream is the psyches attempt to rework a
traumatic event that you may have
experienced those of you that have had
some trauma in your lives such as a car
accident or an assault will often dream
of the incident sometimes the dream is
an exact recall of the incident but at
other times it is an attempt to rework
the incident these dreams can feel like
movies you rent on DVD that have
alternate endings that you can watch the
psyche is just trying to make sense of
something intense and the unconscious is
working on the event while you sleep
bear in mind that there is never a time
that the psyche at some level is not
working even while you're asleep so for
those of you that are having to deal
with trauma remember that the psyche is
working away the trauma even when you're
unconscious this can of course be quite
disruptive for you especially when you
feel that you are getting a grip on the
trauma so treat these dreams as the
psyches attempt to heal pay attention to
the details of the dreams as the psyche
is trying to give you direct information
on the unfinished working through of the
Roma another type of dream is the
childhood dream most of us can recall a
powerful dream that we had as a child
often one that repeats itself I think
that Freud made a superb observation and
one that young himself seemed to agree
with that some childhood dreams are
about wish fulfillment the child has a
powerful desire for something say an
object or an experience and the psyche
gives it to the child at night in the
form of a dream children to have other
kinds of dreams that I'm discussing here
so don't regard all your kids dreams as
simple wish fulfillments the next type
of dream is the recurrent dream this is
often a dream that has the same actions
or outcomes or the same themes to it we
tend to get these dreams throughout our
life what the psyche is doing in these
dreams is drawing your attention to
something very important that needs to
be worked through a good example of a
recurrent dream and I'm sure many of you
who have experienced this type is a
dream that repeats itself exactly in the
same way the very next night my sense of
these dreams is that the psyche gave us
a comment the first night but we didn't
attend to it in the appropriate way in
other words we didn't interpret it and
make a shift in our conscious attitude
so the psyche simply said to the ego
well my friend I sent you this movie to
help you see what you need to change in
your approach to life but you
deliberately ignored it so I'm going to
make you watch it all over again so that
maybe this time you'll get it imagine if
you went to a movie theater watch the
movie but the very next night you went
to the same movie theater and watch the
same movie one assumes that by the end
of the second viewing you've got the
message
the last type of dream I want to deal
with today is the prospect of dream now
this is a form of a dream that is often
misunderstood in essence the prospect of
dream is giving information or
commentary about a future conscious
attitude and sometimes even a future
event what the prospect of dream is not
is a fortune-telling dream
beware literal understandings of dreams
the prospect of dream is a way that the
psyche is able to make sense of the
direction you're heading in with the way
you are living your life and gives you a
commentary on where you'll end up if you
don't begin to correct that conscious
attitude
what about nasty dreams wait maybe I've
skipped something here what about those
dreams where I do some very very bad
things like hurting other people or
killing pets or sleeping with my wife's
best friend what about those kind of
dreams well these are not a separate
category of dreams at all yes but John
you say what if someone found out that I
was dreaming of killing someone else
doesn't it mean that there's a real risk
of me actually doing this well not
really not not at all
you also more than likely have dreams in
which you fly without the aid of an
aeroplane
does this mean you should report the
nearest NASA office and say that you
flew without any assistance and maybe
you can get the next shuttle off the
ground to the International Space
Station for free or you may have dreams
of a dragon does this mean that they
actually exist or you dreamt you're able
to swim with blue whales to the depth of
a thousand feet and not have to breathe
or get crushed by the awful pressure
does this mean that you're likely to
succeed in this form of swimming
the answer to all of these questions is
clearly not we dream of the most
incredible things we do things in dreams
that we could never do in conscious life
or commit atrocious acts that we would
never contemplate doing in our everyday
life these are just the normal healthy
products of the unconscious the message
the unconscious tries to convey to you
comes in the form of some amazing scenes
imagine if we dreamt each night of a
typed list of things we had to deal with
and that was all the dream was about
that would be so boring no dragons no
flying no incredible sex the dream
assembles its meaning in a wonderful
colorful intense series of symbols we
are not responsible for the nature of
our dreams but we are responsible for
listening to them and interpreting them
and making changes to our conscious
attitude so if you dream of doing
something really nasty or cruel we know
that the unconscious really grabs your
attention and there is a stronger
likelihood of you interpreting the dream
then if you read a type list of things
that you should do the next day and your
conscious life so let's just summarize
what we have covered in these two
episodes on dream interpretation I said
in the previous episode that there are
three very important ideas that one has
to hold on to as you approach a dream
interpretation the first thing is that
the interpretation has to fit the
dreamer so even if you feel competent in
your dream interpretation skill and you
are helping somebody else interpret
their own dream if the interpretation
that you offered to the dreamer is not
agreed upon or doesn't fit the dreamer
then consider this interpretation wrong
because at the end of the day if the
dreamer doesn't agree with the
interpretation they're not going to make
the necessary conscious attitude changes
that the dream is requesting second
issue was the fact that I really
strongly recommend against thrashing a
dream and by thrashing a dream I mean
over interpreting the dream so
interpreting it far2 in greater detail
and interpreting it to the extent that
you end up with the dream feeling quite
lifeless as a very very common mistake
we all make when we start dream
interpretation work the third thing I
said that would be useful in your
approach to dream interpretation was
that the dream offers a comment not a
prescription so be wary of taking a
literal approach to the dream if for
example you dream of buying a new car it
doesn't mean that tomorrow morning you
go down to the local car dealership and
buy a new car in addition to the one you
already have we then looked at the issue
of sleep and we remember that we spend
about a third of our life asleep and
there are two major physiological states
in sleep one being non REM and the other
being REM both of which have dreams
occurring in them but it is the REM
dream that is the one we tend to recall
more easily primarily because it's more
intense we also know that while we're in
either of these two stages of sleep
there are very different physiological
changes that we experience non REM is
basically restorative sleep where the
body heals and repairs itself and REM is
very active sleep in which we have these
intense dreams in rem we have a form of
skeletal muscle paralysis
so we don't trash around and hurt
ourselves or someone else in our bed we
also looked at some of the reasons why
we spend so much time interpreting our
dreams and the core 12 reasons that I
gave in the previous podcast are that
dreams provide the most direct access to
unconscious material they compensate and
complement our conscious attitudes they
tell the situation of the psyche as it
is right now dreams are not distorted by
eager defenses hence they provide very
accurate comments they provide access to
subjective inner experiences and they
also provide pure symbolic or a magic
representations of the archetypes dreams
can also provide very specific
information to the analyst and can be
really useful in diagnosing aspects of
neurotic conditions that we all suffer
at some stage of our life
finally dreams facilitate healing and
are essential to the individuation
process